another charge today in goma in north
kivu province
dozens of congolese protesters are
demanding the un peacekeeping mission
called monusco leave the country
the military and police have been called
in to help contain the situation
un personnel are being relocated
the trouble began on monday after a
logistics base was attacked people threw
stones looted office equipment and other
material
this is what was left after it was
ransacked
other un bases have also been targeted
we've been watching the un mission since
the start they have the logistical
capacity they need what are they doing
with that this is why we need to kick
them out
the relationship between some congolese
and the un has been tense at best
the protesters say the u.n has failed to
protect them from frequent attacks
the un peacekeeping mission in
democratic republic of congo has heard a
presence here for more than 20 years
despite this more than a hundred rebel
groups in the east control the versed
region that is rich in minerals
i came to protest against monuca it has
been years since the mission came to
congo many congolese have been killed in
the east
people in goma are fleeing again to
safer areas until the situation gets
better many congolese say they are tired
they want peace and if the u.n cannot
provide stability then its forces need
to leave
catherine soy al jazeera